What the heck is quantum computing?
And should I care?
Hey guys, Crystal here with DNews,
I dont know if you’ve noticed lately, but
there is a new wave of computer technology
being quietly developed in basement labs and
secret company offices.
I’m talking about “quantum computing”.
Companies like Google, Microsoft and IBM,
not to mention the U.S. government, have started
investing heavily in the development of quantum
computers in the last few years and news of
their investments is slowly leaking out into
mainstream media.
So what is a quantum computer and why are
all of the major powers that influence our
lives interested in them?
Well the short answer is that they promise
to be faster, safer, and better at solving
certain kinds of problems than our trusty
laptops.
but that’s only one part of the quantum
picture.
First off lets figure out what it means for
something to be “quantum”.
Sometimes “quantum” is used interchangeably
with “small” but that’s not accurate.
Quantum things are happening on all length
scales all the time--the distinction is that
the likelihood that we notice these corrections
on top of Newton’s “classical” physics
decreases rapidly the bigger you get ...weird.
At the quantum level, a particle can teleport,
travel backwards in time, be “entangled”
with a distant cousin, and a hypothetical
cat in a box can be both alive and dead.
This apparently fantastical behavior is all
possible because of science… well, physics
really … and a little math.
Most relevant to our quantum computing plot
is the idea of “superposition” which transcends
classical deterministic outcomes: alive or
dead, heads or tails, 0 or 1, to describe
these states as a distribution of probabilities:
“the cat has a 70% probability of being
alive” and as a funny outcome of the science
we don’t get a fixed answer until we actually
open the box and observe the cat, take a measurement,
or otherwise ask the system for a specific
output.
A computer capable of exploiting this and
other quantum properties, like entanglement,
would not be constrained by a classical computer’s
need to perform calculations sequentially
because quantum bits would be capable of existing
in a probability of many states and thus,
be much better at tasks like simulating molecular
bonds, performing rapid searches of complicated
databases, or factoring large numbers very
quickly.
These examples may seem silly or irrelevant
until you learn, for instance, that factorization
is prohibitively time-consuming for a classical
computer, which is why it forms one common
approach to data encryption.
Now, quantum computers are looking pretty
good, especially if you have an interest in
National Security.
So how close are we to a programmable quantum
computer?
Noooooot that close.
You’ll probably use one in your lifetime,
but don’t run out to find one in the store
just yet.
Research in this area is happening at a rapid
rate and has even resulted in the Nobel Prize
for Physics in 2012, but scientists still
have a long way to go.
Challenges arise both from the difficulty
in control and manipulation of quantum states,
something that makes encoding quantum information
difficult, as well as the vulnerability of
that information to disturbance from the environment.
Nevertheless, scientists like those at Caltech’s
Institute for Quantum Information and Matter,
are working at the cutting edge of our current
knowledge to make quantum computing a reality.
And as for it’s potential, being able to
simulate molecular interactions to create
optimized materials on demand seems reason
enough for Google, Microsoft and IBM to throw
tons of money at quantum computing, But as
one scientist recently reminded me: Who would
have been able to foresee the impact of Facebook
or the internet when classical computing was
in development?
What do you think?
Will quantum computation change the world?
Subscribe to DNews and let us know in the
comments down below.
And come find me on twitter @PolycrystalhD